[Musique]
voici des jeunes filles comme les autres
elles sont jeunes elles aiment rire
s'habiller sortir manger et pourtant ne
sont pas tout à fait comme les autres
ce sont quelques-unes des 45 féminines
de l'ol l'om qui donne deux joueuses à
l'équipe nationale
marlène farrugia l'avant-centre agressé
plus souvent qu'à son tour et josiane
marcassoli la gardienne de but
le football féminin sport comme les
autres et pourtant cet om là est encore
moins prise au sérieux que l'un
certaines équipes premières ça vous
arrive de vous mettre en jupe berra
roman pourquoi je sais pas je vous
trouve mis un pantalon pour tous
plus à l'aise tu as zannese oui mais ce
qu'une femme ait pas plus femme en rouge
reçu pour une mission c'est un sport
qu'il faut laisser je pense aux garçons
et c'est un avis tout à fait personnel
maintenant il ya des filles que j'ai vu
évoluer notamment à l'équipe de rêve qui
se débrouille très bien mais elles sont
juste à la limite entre le garçon et la
fille donc je pense qu'il faut les
laisser leur féminité
[Musique]
ce n'est quand même pas un sport qui est
fait pour les femmes
je pense qu'elles peuvent arriver à un
bon niveau technique physiquement
personnellement je m'occupe d'une équipe
féminine
j'attache beaucoup d'importance à la
technique mais peu au travail physique
et pourtant c'est un sport dur pour des
jambes de jeune fille
on se prépare au match par trois
entraînements hebdomadaires et on
supporte les blessures grâce à l'aide
des parents très beaucoup d'occasions
beaucoup de symptômes j'étais beaucoup
de peines seulement j'avais beaucoup de
chance pas le temps du lieu date le
maire de footballeuses non régulièrement
championne de provence cette année les
féminines de l'om réussit l'exploit
battre reims l'invs ainsi le secret de
leur réussite
entraînement et absence de complexes
vous faites aux régimes non je fais
beaucoup de sport alors je passe bien de
faire de réchy
et le joueur de football que vous aimez
le plus tempo l'escale est l'homme que
vous aimez le plus football au féminin
il n'ya pas contresens entre ces deux
mots non je ne pense pas d'ailleurs on
l'a déjà prouvé
et les filles je faisais du basket
faisait dual tout ça je vois pas
pourquoi elle ne ferait pas du football
vous êtes présent aujourd'hui devant une
marche 10 ans de niveau très moyen
j'aurais voulu simplement que vous
puissiez voir des niveaux championnat de
france ne serait-ce que contre reims où
lyon ou même plus signal qui sont des
équipes renommées d'un championnat de
france féminin très esthétique feu
techniquement c'est pas mauvais mais
disons qu'elle manque de punch surtout
dans
construction milieu de terrain quelle
différence y at-il entre l'équipe 2
féminine de l'om et celle de reims à
reims est plus technique je pense votre
footballeurs préférés ceux qui qui
gagnent
[Musique]